picture yourself next to tram tracks in
the distance a trolley is racing gun
controllably towards five workers who
cannot hear it even if they see it they
won't have time to escape you see a
liver by the tracks pulling it would
send the trolley onto another track away
from the five workers but there is
another worker on this other track
unaware like the others which you pull
the liver causing one death but saving
five
this scenario is at the heart of the
well-known trolley problem a thought
experiment first introduced by
philosopher Philip aut in 1967 and later
revised by Judith Thompson in
1985 the trolley problem encourages us
to ponder the results of our actions and
question if the rightness of an action
is based only on its outcome now think
about a different version of this
problem you're on a bridge above the tra
tracks down below a runaway trolley is
speeding towards five workers who don't
know it's coming this time there is no
liver to change its course but there is
a large man next to you it seems likely
that if he were on the tracks he could
stop the trolley would you push him onto
the tracks trading his life to save the
five workers the end result here is the
same as in the liver scenario One Life
lost five saved yet it's curious to note
that while many people might pull a
liever to divert danger far fewer feel
comfortable with the idea of pushing
someone to prevent the same danger the
truly problem underscores the conflict
between two schools of moral thought
utilitarianism and deontological ethics
utilitarianism famously espoused by
philosophers like John Stuart Mill and
Jeremy Bentham posits that the right
action is the one that maximizes overall
happiness or utility from a utilitarian
perspective pulling deliver is the
morally correct Choice as it results in
fewer lives lost and greater overall
utility on the other hand deontological
ethics a theory associated with Emmanuel
Kant argues that morality is rooted in
Duty and rules and the consequences of
actions are not the sole factor in
determining their morality K's famous
Maxim Act only according to that Maxim
whereby you can at the same time will
that it should become a universal law
suggest that the morality of an action
is determined by whether its principle
can be universally applied in the
context of the trolley problem a
deontologist might argue that pulling
the liver constitutes a deliberate
action to harm an individual which
cannot be morally Justified even if it
results in fewer deaths the problem
becomes even more complex when
variations are introduced for instance
what if the one person on the alternate
track is a Renown scientist who research
could save thousands of lives could this
change the moral calculus these
variations demonstrate that moral
decision making is not always black and
white they highlight the difficulty of
creating a universal ethical rule that
can be applied to every situation one
significant aspect of the trolley
problem is its exploration of the
difference between doing harm and
allowing harm when we choose to pull the
liver we actively participate in the
outcome this active participation is
often seen as morally different from
passively allowing the trolley to
continue on its path resulting in the
death of five this distinction Echoes a
fundamental question in moral philosophy
is there a moral difference between
doing harm and merely allowing harm to
happen in 2001 Joshua green and his team
pioneered a significant study on
people's reactions to trolley problems
using functional MRI they found that
personal dilemas like pushing someone
off a bridge activated emotion brain
regions while impersonal ones like
flipping a switch to divert a trolley
involved more reasoning areas in 2017
Michael Stevens group conducted the
first realistic trolley problem
experiment participants thinking they
were in a train switching station
watched what they believed were live
feeds of a train heading towards workers
most chose not to divert the train
surveys on the trolley problem show us
about 90% of people would sacrifice one
person to save five this however changes
when the lone individual is a loved one
the trolly problem can be applied in
various disciplines consider the
application of the trolley problem in
law a judge May face a trolley like
decision when sentencing an individual
whose crime was committed under unsure
circumstances the judge's dilemma is
whether to punish the individual for the
broader deterrent effect or to consider
the individual circumstances that led to
the crime the trolley problem here
Echoes the words of 18th century jurist
Sir William Blackstone it is better that
10 guilty persons Escape than that one
innocent suffer which means it is better
to be on the side of caution when
convicting someone of a crime to falsely
convict and imprison someone is a
terrible thing to do in the medical
field the trolley problems implications
become starkly evident in the allocation
of scarce resources such as during the
covid-19 pandemic when ventilators were
in short supply Physicians often had to
make difficult decisions about which
patients would receive life-saving
interventions this brings to mind the
hypocritic Oaths principle of Do no harm
which becomes complicated when it is
impossible to not harm the Advent of
autonomous vehicles has transported the
trolley problem from philosophical texts
into engineering Labs programmers must
embed moral decisions into algorithms
should an autonomous car swear to avoid
a group of pedestrians if it means
endangering the life of its passenger
here the trolley problem transcends
philosophical debate and demands
practical application reflecting the
concerns of Technology ethicist Shannon
Valor who said technology is driving the
future but who is steering in my
perspective the trolley problem stands
without a definitive resolution this
philosophical conundrum isn't crafted
for solution but rather to stir
contemplation and Foster intellectual
dialogue recognizing the complexities of
morality and our own constraints as
moral beings it is obvious that most
people would pull the liver but why that
is a question what goes on inside our
head that urges us to think that
sacrificing a person is better for the
common good why don't we just stay
passive and would we really act so in a
real scenario how would we feel after
doing that these are hard questions that
require hard thinking I'm not sure if
the this discourse surrounding the
trolley problem is about finding answers
but more about understanding the
importance of the reasoning behind those
choices when we reason we become more
conscious about our decisions not every
viewpoint on the trolley problem is
equally defensible we must admit that
some resolutions are more justifiable
than others and through reasoning and
debate wins closer to them I believe
that a Flawless answer to the trolley
problem or a universal agreement the
optimum solution is unattainable what we
can and indeed should strive for is to
apply philosophical thought and
scientific inquiry to perpetuate this
discussion the trolley problem doesn't
need to be solved it should be
considered and Revisited in our
dialogues periodically morality is at
the core of our social Fabric and it is
constantly haunted especially now a days
where Wars are breaking out like it's
the most normal thing our morality is
haunted by religion it is haunted by
ideology it is haunted by nationalism it
is haunted by dogmatism my whole life I
have been trying to see clearly through
all these noise and come up with moral
solutions to problems that I have to
face and it hasn't been easy it will
never be but at least I'm
trying uhoh Nicholas this train is going
to crash into these five people should
we move the train to go this way or
should we let it go that way which way
should the train
go this
way
uhoh